Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. We're continuing section two on the cancer genes and we're going to be looking at the energy genes.
So typically the genes that are producing energy in your body. Remember, you have to produce ATP or energy in order to survive.
So you do so through looking at the enzymes that are produced through these genes. Oh, there's a number of genes and gene families in these.
The mitochondrial energy genes and how you get nutrients into the cell. So all these different gene families mean different things.
For instance, this cartotene genes here is how you get fatty acids into the cell in order to get through the fatty acid cycle and to produce ATP.
This person has some issues there. So that may be an issue that is causing some fatigue, whether this person has cancer or not.
This could be a fatigue issue. Remember, even if you have cancer, all these genes on your genetic report, you had when you were born, these defects that you have, you had when you were born.
So you don't have these defects here. This person doesn't have these defects because they have cancer.
So, but you added environmental insult environmental stress or on top of somebody who's born with a genetic picture like this.
This could be a reason why they have a greater amount of fatigue. So if they didn't have as many defects or variants on some of these genes that cause that hard to create energy, would they have as much fatigue, maybe not.
So that's what we want to look at is the how can we help affect this person's symptom, symptom pattern by looking at the genetics and supporting some of these pathways.
Now when we talk about energy production, it's really important to know, especially if we have a cancer diagnosis, how energy is made.
So let's look at this little handy date chart here. So when you take food in, food is going to be broken down into glucose, particularly carbohydrates are going to be broken down into glucose.
And the rate of that breakdown is important. That's why you want things with a high glycemic index so that you're not breaking down foods too quickly into glucose and flooding the body with glucose.
So that'd be the feeder of cancer. Now all glucose is going to feed cancer because cancer needs to do a cancer cell has to be fed this exact same way also.
So it a person that does not have cancer, carbohydrates are broken down into glucose, goes through a process right here called glycolysis, which spits out a few ATP.
It ultimately ends up with a compound called pyruvate or pyruvic acid.
Now pyruvate converts through the PDH gene with influence over it through the HIF1 genes.
So these two genes, the HIF1 gene and the PDH gene are going to be really important because they are time-limited factors on the conversion of pyruvate into this product right here called acetylcoidzyme.
Acetylcoidzyme, though this is taking place in the mitochondria, is the first step to go into the crem cycle.
So you got these limiting factors here, PDH gene defects and HIF gene defects that can hinder pyruvates conversion to acetylcoidzyme to get it into the crem cycle to make a whole bunch of energy.
Now I know this gets a little technical, but on a warburg discovered years ago that many people with cancer, not everybody, but many people with cancer.
The cancer is feeding off of lactic acid or lactate in an anaerobic environment.
Why is that? This is a very inefficient way to make energy into utilize energy.
It's much more efficient as far as how much energy you will produce.
If you could convert pyruvate to acetylcoidzyme, get it into the crem cycle and spit out a ton of energy.
This is where you really kick out energy here, but why is it that cancer cells tend to feed off of lactate?
Well, I was thought of for many, many years that it was just a pH imbalance of the cell or a mitochondrial defect and some sort, some sickness in the mitochondria.
Not really be able to put a figure out of it when we start looking at genetics, we start to discover that people that tend to get cancer patients that tend to have their cancer feed off of lactate.
We see a lot of pdh and a lot of hif gene defects.
So that's one thing that we'll look at in this pathway.
So in this initial energy pathway, we're looking at cartotene, peaked genes.
This is a limiting step here on the formation of acetylcoidzyme as well, the FAD genes, the ACAD genes.
These are very important genes as far as converting and getting energy from your fats, your SLC1 genes, and your ASTSL1 genes.
And then some other genes here that are imported in converting things through the CREM cycle.
So we're looking at cancer, we're looking at the most important ones are the ACAD genes, the FADs are imported, the peaked genes are important.
These are a little bit less important with cancer, and then some genes that are to this report that we pull up separately, which are the pdh genes and the hif genes.
We look at that to see how cancer is being fed, good chance of how the fuel source, the fuel line that is feeding the cancer.
And also to help comfort a person through maybe a lot of fatigue and how we could support them so that we're not feeding the cancer, but we're stimulating the CREM cycle and be able to produce ATP this way.
The glucose is being constantly robbed this way to feed the cancer, we're not getting any nutrients into the CREM cycle through acetyl quids.
I Bay and this person ends up with a lot of fatigue.
So looking at the genes gives us clues on how to support that pathway and to cut off this pathway.
Alright, as always, just remind you that this is not a substitute for your other care, and we'll continue to add videos to this living book.
Thanks much.
Bye-bye.